[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas le jour j mais le jour cap
qu'akon kennedy coiffé d'un
haut-de-forme comme le veut le protocole
john fitzgerald kennedy 35e président
des états unis a solennellement pris ses
fonctions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ak l'hymne national chanté par marian
anderson le plus jeune président que les
états unis aient jamais élu a prêté le
serment traditionnel sur la bible après
avoir reçu des félicitations de son
concurrent dixon et de son prédécesseur
le général eisenhower
le nouvel hôte de la maison blanche a
prononcé son premier discours officiel
[Applaudissements]
nous ne devons jamais négocié dans la
peur mais nous ne devons jamais avoir
peur de négocier telle est la première
formule du président kennedy formule qui
a aujourd'hui dans le monde entier un
retentissement que n'ont pas couvert les
fanfares et les applaudissements du
défilé final défilé digne en tout de
cette prestigieuse inauguration c'est le
mot qu'on emploie outre atlantique et
qui met là comme il se doit la ba les
troupes les drapeaux les fausses indien
les classiques majorettes et même un
bison
bienvenue à kennedy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
texas tower numéro 4 n'existe plus la
tente est l'engloutît avec ses 28 ans
c'était l'un de ces îlots artificiels
édifié comme autant d'observatoire
avancé de la défense américaine ces
radars pouvant détecter une attaque
une minute avant ceux du continent une
minute qui compte
le porte-avions wasps et ses
hélicoptères ont patrouillé en vain les
28 hommes ont péri corps et biens avec
1961 l'aviation commerciale est entré de
plain-pied si l'on peut dire dans l'ère
du jet les distances se sont abolis ou
presque puisque new york n'est plus qu'à
8 heures de paris les capitales se sont
rapprochés paris moscou
4h35
et le réseau d'air france le plus long
du monde avec ses 325 1000 km est devenu
le plus rapide avec son parc d'avions à
réaction
17 boeing et 24 carats belle une flotte
puissante basée sur l'unité de moyens 17
boeing
c'est une capacité simultanée de deux
mille cent soixante seize passagers à
destination des quatre coins du globe et
pour lesquels 900 km se réduise pas une
heure
[Applaudissements]
24 caravelle c'est la possibilité de
transporter simultanément 1824 passagers
sur les moyennes distances à gijon 1h15
on peut rêver toutes les villes du monde
à portée de la main
le verre plat c'est en cette saison
l'ennemi le plus terrible parce que le
plus secret le plus imprévus en un mot
le plus traître
bien sûr les ponts et chaussées ne sont
pas désarmés
chaque soir les camions remplis de sable
et de sel sont prêts à intervenir
[Musique]
mieux au long de l'autoroute on
expérimente des appareils détecteurs de
verglas qui donne la larve
[Musique]
aloïs ipc police à l'aide de verglas
la larme da déclenché deux opérations
celle d'abord qui incombe à la police
les motards vont reconnaître les plaques
de verre plat en formation et en faire
connaître l'importance au service des
ponts et chaussées
[Musique]
la plaque de verglas commence après le
pont de la bifurcation d'orly environ à
50 mètres mais les motards vont aussi
veiller à la sécurité des automobilistes
en attendant le déroulement de la
seconde opération le sablage de la zone
dangereuse par les camions des ponts et
chaussées sans doute on ne peut songer
encore adopté toutes les routes d'un tel
dispositif alors automobilistes écouter
les conseils de votre radio de bord
circulation difficile et même dangereuse
sur la nationale 3 188 aux environs de
saint rémy
un détour peut vous éviter bien des
ennuis
lorsque le temps risque d'être propice
au verglas dit vous aussi qu'une vitesse
réduite peut vous éviter de sérieux
déboires penser à être prudent c'est
votre meilleure arme et ne pensez pas
que cela ne peut pas vous arriver à vous
on en a vu d'eau
[Musique]
certains esprits inventifs se sont
penchés sur ce problème du verglas
bien entendu ils n'ont pas tardé à
trouver un arm est le remède
le voici une bande de caoutchouc d'un
diamètre supérieur à celui du pneu est
maintenue relativement lâche par une
armature la bande de caoutchouc adhère
au sol glissant le pneu rôle sur la
bande et tour est joué le système de
lâche ni peut-être en belgique
l'invention obéit au souci du moindre
effort et le siège ce temps de lui même
au conducteur
plus besoin de s'échiner à manoeuvrer
la voiture se sort elle même du
stationnement par translation latéral et
ça n'est pas tout le coffre dissimule
tout un appareillage sans aucun doute
électronique
et voici la voiture qu'on a plus besoin
de se donner le mal de conduire pour la
raison très simple qu elle se conduit
toute seule
encore un miracle du radar l'antenne
détecte les obstacles et les freins font
le reste
la voiture sans chauffeur enfin bébé
éprouvette bébé artificiel on en est pas
encore tout à fait là mais le professeur
petrucci et son équipe de bologne ont
peut-être par leurs travaux ouvert la
voie en obtenant pendant 29 jours le
développement d'un embryon humain en
laboratoire les biologistes bolognais
ont pu enregistrer de bout en bout cette
expérience en adaptant à leurs
microscopes un appareil de prise de vue
cinématographique il dispose aujourd'hui
d'un film pour étudier les phases du
processus de la naissance de l'homme et
en particulier l'instant de la
fécondation
on va voir sur l'écran à gauche le vil
pénétrer par le spermatozoïde
[Musique]
en réussissant à prolonger le
développement de neuf féconder pendant
neuf jours le professeur petrucci a
marqué sans aucun doute un jalon
important sur le chemin de la
connaissance
deuxième grande épreuve internationale
de la saison de ski à kitzbühel en
autriche avec le hahnenkamm le jeune
autrichien henning avec l'audace de ses
20 ans se joue de toutes les difficultés
du ca l'homme et par la même occasion de
ses adversaires puisqu'il remporte
l'épreuve devant le français guy
périllat sperian prend pas trop de
risque il sait qu'il est le champion
numéro un pour lui un seul objectif la
première place du combiné pour qu'on
veut à tous qu'il est inscrit en contre
[Applaudissements]
le français bozon lui c'est le styliste
il se contente d'une démonstration en
souplesse qui lui assure cependant la 8e
place du slalom ce qui aurait quand même
pu lui valoir un joli coup de chapeau
[Musique]
mais la vérité du skieur ne s'exprime
que par la vitesse dans cette spécialité
guy périllat est imbattable c'est le
super champion
avant l'épreuve on sait qu'il va gagner
c'est décourageant pour ses adversaires
textile toni sailer l'ancien champion
olympique on est tous rêvaient
[Musique]
l'autrichien denning à pau forcé tant
qu'il le peut il est bien obligé de
s'incliner
guy périllat est incontestablement le
meilleur skieur de la saison
[Musique]